people in the small Coastal Village of
fast boy are angry that dozens of people
from their Community have died at Sea
the protesters are pulled wood and farm
machinery into the road and set it to
light this is the first of several
burning roadblocks along this road
leading all the way down to the landing
stage on the Atlantic Ocean where more
than a month ago a small wooden boat set
sail with about a hundred people on
board it was about two days ago when
that boat was spotted by a Spanish
fishing vessel adrift about 300
kilometers off the island of Sal part of
the Cape Verde Islands that prompted a
rescue operation by Cape verde's Coast
Guard which is about 600 kilometers into
the Atlantic Ocean from here and the
Coast Guard says that they rescued about
40 survivors they said they found
several dead bodies on board the boat
and dozens more of the people who were
thought to be on board are missing there
are dozen of shipwrecks every year as
people try to Traverse this route and
hundreds of deaths Cape Verde is seen as
a gateway to the Spanish Canary Islands
Spain is part of the European Union so
people see this as a possible route to a
better and safer life